uh i hope you've enjoyed your day of
press
it's good you they saved the best to a
last
uh am i the last interview you're the
second from last okay
that's why he said saves the best for
last anyway i don't know who's next
i'm i'm totally [ __ ] with you um
so a bunch of questions if you have if
someone has never seen
anything that you've directed what do
you want them to start with first
oh i mean
i don't think there's any kind of um
entry level like sort of i think any
it's the same with like some movies you
know like um
like you know with the james bond movies
it doesn't matter which one you start
with it's whichever one you saw first so
i think with my movies
like um i don't mind whatever movie they
want to watch first and stuff it's
always interesting to me when you hear
about people's kids that like the movies
is what their first film was
you know like i hear from a lot of
people that oh my son really loves scott
pilgrim because that's something they
watching when they were young but it
there's there's no kind of um there's no
entry level like i you know
you could start with one or something
like that and work up to maybe i don't
know i can't answer that question what
would you say steve
uh i don't have an answer for that
because i think it depends on i listen i
i would recommend all your movies so i'd
say start with sean and then just work
your way through
i would i would i don't have the answer
i say don't start with fistful of
fingers
um who was the the newspaper dress from
last night in soho
that is a good question i'm not sure
anybody has that maybe it's probably
perished and fallen apart by this point
i don't i definitely don't have it and
neither does christy i think you'd have
to ask a deal with dicks moreau but like
maybe it's falling apart
i'm very disappointed by this um of the
films that you've made uh which of them
went through the biggest changes in the
editing room and why
um
i think um i think probably
in some ways that this one in the sense
of actually
not in terms of changing radically from
the the script
more that when we did some additional
filming and especially because we had a
break enforced on us i don't know if you
heard about the pandemic that we're
still going um but like but we when we
returned we we had to sort of you know
go on hiatus for six months and we were
already planning to shoot some stuff but
it did give us some thinking time so it
was something where we didn't
necessarily change scenes but we did
redo some parts of scenes and rewrite
them so it was actually sort of the most
kind of surgical
like sort of
um additional stuff that i'd ever done
and and i i'm always like kind of in awe
when i watch it back that it's it's
pretty damn seamless even to the point
where our cinematographer chung chun
hoon couldn't tell
which shots were which anymore so i took
that as a compliment
uh you have pulled off in your movies
some really effing cool shots when you
think back including this film which
shot
ended up being the one that almost broke
you the one that was just really really
hard
um
oh that's a good question
i mean i think the ones that are like
long extended takes like we're usually
smart enough to rehearse them a lot so i
don't think i've ever tried to do
something on set like that which we
haven't already really like planned out
and so some of the sort of most
complicated shots
in this movie
would be ones that we'd rehearsed
i mean even like a shot like you know
usually it's the thing where they're the
things that broke me are like other
things they're not they're things that
you wouldn't think would be that
difficult the thing that kind of really
broke my brain on this
was timing the neon lights to the music
in sometimes in three different camera
speeds and sometimes in scenes where
there was like the color continuity of
the french flag that's outside
eloise's window and which set which
which which revolves in it's the order
of the french flag
and you know then trying to sort of keep
continuity of the color within a scene
and then having like lights that were
sort of triggered by the music that they
would be in time in the music the
overall finished effect is incredibly
slick but it did give me and my editor
paul matchlist
a complete headache on set so if i have
ptsd about anything from this shoot it's
that
weirdly like the one is the big sort of
like extended kind of like steady cam
shots with
six texas switches in a row or thomasin
walking across the haymarket one of the
busiest streets in london
we'd at least rehearsed those on camera
already the widley with the one in
london when she walks across the
thunderball marquee we couldn't rehearse
it in the location because we only had
that location from 10 30 p.m to 2 30 a.m
so we rehearsed it on an airstrip with
all of the kind of like the you know the
kind of the lanes marked out and the
cars and the even the bus you know i'm
just imagining you and i would imagine
you might not be pleasant to be around
when you're trying to figure all that
out in the editing room with the colors
and the timing and all that it's not in
the editing room it's on the set
i meant i meant on set like that's the
day to just to avoid you
i mean i don't i'm not a shelter i'm
just kind of like a sulker i'd probably
just sitting sitting in the corner like
rubbing my beard thinking to myself
whose stupid idea was this oh god it was
my idea why did i why did i make it so
complicated for myself
uh simon and nick have both talked about
you being a perfectionist i am curious
uh what is the most amount of takes you
have done
on any shot
that's a good question i don't think
i've ever gone crazy high i've never
been like a stanley kubrick or david
fincher this i've never done like a
hundred takes or something i think the
ma and usually if it's going that high
it's not because something it's usually
if something physical is not working um
as in like a prop or
it's a very good question i i can't
remember ever going above like
i mean maybe the baby driver opening
credits shot we did 28 takes that might
be one of the highest and the thing is
is that eventually the take we used to
take 21
and if that thing would take 21 there
was one thing that bill pope was unsure
about and he said let's get another one
just to be safe
and then after another like seven takes
that we're getting worse we said you
know what [ __ ] it 21 is the take
it's interesting i've spoken to fincher
and he talks about how sometimes
the way he crafts a
scene will be he'll use some of take 8
some of take 12 some of take 18. it's
just interesting how he pulls together a
performance obviously he does it kind of
good
yeah i mean you can do that and
certainly in terms of sound and dialogue
editing you know that's that's that's
very possible and and sometimes the
point where i don't think the actor
would even know that you
you know like sort of i mean sometimes
you can have that like it can happen
you know there was a shot in the world's
end where like there was a performance
of a line that simon really liked that
was in a take that happened to be
slightly soft so with a bit of like
editing magic you could take the line
reading that he likes and put it onto
the sharp take
um do you do extensive coverage of all
of your scenes or let me stop there i'm
just curious the way you shoot a scene
um
and how much coverage you like to do
well it depends like in some of those
sequences where there are like sort of
it's a it's a very specific shot for a
scene like some of those mirror shots or
like the elongated
like dance numbers and stuff there is no
other take you know so you're you're
really like wedding yourself to this is
going to be in the movie like this
because it's like there's no like wide
shot
so i think with action scenes
and dance sequences you basically shoot
like how you want
the scene to be edited
like with any of the kind of the action
scenes in baby driver
because it's all like linked to the song
it's not that they're you you do like a
really long take of everything you just
use you just shoot the part of the setup
that you need same with like scott
pilgrim is all of those fight scenes
that were you know brilliantly
coordinated by the late brad allen
god rest his soul um
you know we would shoot it in that hong
kong style where it's like this is the
shop for this bit of action and then
this is the shop for the next bit of
action you wouldn't do like coverage you
sort of commit to an angle
in there's a tv ad for this movie where
um i saw a shot with like some wallpaper
and it says help me but i don't remember
that being in the movie am i wrong about
this
no it's not in the movie but it will be
in the deleted scenes eventually with
something that we cut out and when we
put it in the trailer i was like oh fine
you know throw him throw him off it was
in the movie at one point
uh
what did you end up how many deleted
scenes on the eventual blu-ray
uh
[Laughter]
two three four five six seven seven
are you working on it right now
well i just had a list of them right in
my hand no i mean it's i think
the thing is i always feel with those
scenes is that they're gone for a reason
you know i think i've said this to you
before it's like kind of taking
something out as an amputation it's like
painful to do but as soon as it's gone
you don't miss it it feels better
um and
you know like i i usually include those
for people who are interested in
filmmaking i'm not including them in a
sense of like you know people always say
to me or which ending of scott pilgrim
do you like better i say the one in the
movie that's why we re-shot it you know
um
how many minutes of deleted scenes are
there is it like five minutes or just a
few i can't tell you i have to do the
math but it's all stuff it's all stuff
that's interesting just like
in out of context but there's nothing
there's nothing that i miss no
um i want to make sure i pronounce his
name right uh chun hoon
that's how you pronounce it right chiang
chang hoon yeah okay um i am curious how
you ended up working with him because i
think the way you guys collaborated on
this is amazing i'm just curious how did
you guys end up working together
well um it was actually something where
i came together quite late in the day
because bill popel was going to shoot
the movie and then sadly had to drop out
um
but
so
probably about two months before the
start of the shoot i had to find a new
dp
um but what was amazing is chung was one
of the people who was available and
wanted to do it and i was a huge fan of
his work with park chanwook so just the
idea of him doing the movie was very
exciting and also the idea of having
a dp from south korea coming to london
and shooting london streets that i was
very familiar with but i wanted to see
what he brought to the table
and obviously like a lot of his work
with park chan wuk has this sort of dark
opulence to it you know you only have to
look at the handmaiden just the idea of
him doing it was very exciting and i
remember like naira park my producer
said to me if you don't hire chong chang
hoon you'll always be thinking about
what his version of the movie looks like
and i said you're dead right
let's get him and that's why she's a
good producer
yeah and he's an amazing dp i mean like
what a joy to work with as well he's
also given that all of his films are
very dark he's a very silly and goofy
man and that was one of the things was
an added benefit in a quite a stressful
like intense shoot chunk could always
make me laugh
yeah you guys collaborated so
so well on this um before i run out of
time as you know i'm kind of a fan and
i'm asking this as my for as a fan and
as everyone at collider do you know what
you're actually directing next i don't i
mean i know that sounds like a [ __ ]
non-answer but it's true because there's
it's very difficult to like
read or write anything when you're like
promoting another movie and i as you
know i've been promoting two movies this
year so i'm looking forward to the
metaphorical and literal like clean desk
where like even just in a week's time
i'll sort of like the movie you'll be
out and um i can sort of think about
what's next and you know i'm i have some
great things in development and and part
of it though is also it's kind of like
practical decisions obviously in the
world that we live in now is like sort
of like how you want to make a movie
where you want to be so all of those
things come into it as well
i read that you were developing or
working on a running man a new running
man
well steve as you well know like i
nearly made a movie once and i have no
regrets about not making the movie the
only regrets i have are about doing
interviews for it when i didn't actually
make the movie
so i've decided moving forward to never
speak of a movie until it's in the can
oh that's an interesting you've learned
you've learned this from the years of
publicity
i just it's that thing is like the only
the sort of like the only thing that
haunts me is being like the boy who
cried wolf like having interviews in
print about a film that i never made and
i figured i never want to do that again
do you actually have a lot of ideas
slash scripts in the desk that you're
sort of like that you go back to and
look at or you know what i mean like how
much is sitting there in your computer
in terms of ideas for films not in terms
of old ideas
if anything there sometimes they're
ideas that haven't been like written
like so you know there's something that
i've been thinking about which i'd like
to sort of knuckle down and write but it
doesn't exist in a screenplay form yet
so it's not like i have i don't really
have like many like old screenplays no
you know but when me and simon wrote
shawn in the dead it was the first like
proper screenplay either of us had
written so it wasn't like i wasn't like
a luke besson and had all these scripts
that i wrote when i was like 13 that had
been sitting in the drawer waiting to
get the money
i i usually like most the time i've like
you know written the thing that i want
to do next or in the case of like baby
driver or last night
it's an idea that's been formulated for
a long time
so there are not in terms of things that
i've self-generated there are not like a
lot of other scripts kind of like
sitting there
on that note i gotta stop
sir congratulations on this film loved
it i wish you nothing but the best and
hope it's a huge hit
thanks very much always nice to see you
and always like to give you a non-answer
about what i'm doing next
you know something i know i don't do it
deliberately i'm not trying to be cruel
no no i i actually completely understand
after doing this for so long and talking
to so many filmmakers i know there's an
element of like you need to just sit
back and be like what do i really want
to spend the next two years of my life
on you know and like
you know that has to come up
yeah i think it's also you don't want to
be you don't anything that i'd be have
anything and kind of print about
something that you didn't make you know
listen i totally get it um seriously uh
congrats on the movie for real and uh
good luck with your last interview
thanks man
you